not too long ago extreme neoconservative
Warhawk john bolton was hired by donald
trump to be his third national security
advisor of an administration that's
still not even 18 months old you'll
remember Trump's first national security
adviser was Michael Flint he's been
indicted Trump's second national
security adviser was HR McMaster he was
too much of a voice of reason to stay as
Donald Trump's national security adviser
so in comes John Bolton one of the
architects of the Iraq war which Trump
supposedly said was the biggest mistake
of the Bush administration but
nevertheless in comes John Bolton as
Trump's third national security adviser
and immediately after John Bolton's
hiring the United States is announcing
its pulling out of the Iran deal North
Korea blames Bolton in part for the
cancellation of the summit with Trump
which may or may not be back on I guess
we're not really sure at this point we
still have an interview scheduled to
take place from the summit even though
we don't know whether the summit is
actually going on but we'll talk about
that at another point and it's very very
clear that Bolton's sort of
neoconservative Warhawk ism is
immediately having an impact in the
Trump White House and now the latest is
that John Bolton has hired a hate group
executive as his chief of staff
Fred flight's has been hired to run the
staff of the National Security Council
he's been the senior vice president of
Frank Gaffney's center for security
policy and Dylan Williams from J Street
tweeted about this saying John Bolton
has chosen Fred flight's as the new
national security council chief of staff
flights is senior VP of Frank Gaffney
center for security policy a Southern
Poverty Law Center designated hate group
that the anti-defamation league condemns
as quote dedicated to advancement of
myriad conspiracy theories and
anti-muslim extremism this is really
really really bad Frank Gaffney is a
complete extremist lunatic who has
actually had contact with Trump he's one
of these conspiracy theorists many of
the conspiracy theorists are anti-muslim
he said for example that over the last
over the last twenty or so years his
comments have included that Saddam
Hussein was involved in the 1993 World
Trade Center bombing and the Oklahoma
City bombing
that Hillary Clinton's aide humi Abaddon
is a secret agent of the Muslim
Brotherhood which was actually repeated
by people like Michele Bachmann who at
the time was a congresswoman he's
promoted the idea that President Barack
Obama is a secret Muslim that General
David Petraeus former director of the
CIA submitted to Sharia law whatever
that means and many other completely
outrageous conspiracy theories and the
vice president of that organization is
now running the staff of the National
Security Council the National Security
Council responsible for some of the most
important decisions our country makes
about keeping Americans safe and I
encourage you go and read about Frank
Gaffney read about the center for
security policy and you're going to
start to understand how this
administration is the administration of
the extremist hate group right so the
the Bush administration we could say was
an administration subjugated and taken
over by neoconservative Warhawk ISM
right the administration of P knack the
project for a new American Century
people like Rumsfeld and Wolfowitz and
John Bolton and Bill Kristol that line
of thought not all of those people
literally connected to P knack but that
line of thought the Trump administration
is the administration of hate groups and
ideological extremists conspiracy
theorists the people like Jerome Corsi
who during the Obama administration were
saying stuff like Michelle Obama's a man
and I don't know John Brennan is a
secret Muslim or whatever it was that
that guy was saying some of them are now
part of the administration and I guess
it's like a case of pick your poison and
we've talked a little bit about how in a
way Trump surrounding himself with the
more buffoonish nuts
maybe prevents him from doing as
destructive foreign policy as george w
bush was doing although i don't know i
mean these people are pretty capable of
doing really bad things yeah i feel like
there are two wings of the trump
administration now one is the crony
corrupt wing who are just in it to
enrich themselves those people like
Jared Kushner and Steve minuchin and
then there's the deplorable wing and
that includes you know formerly Steve
Bannon yep John Bolton and you can
scratch you can put this guy in as one
of the
Horrible's I think absolutely disgusting
that someone like this would have a
position of such consequence in an
administration but alas that this is
what we're dealing with right now and I
I don't actually have any ideas for how
we might combat this other than voting
these people out and voting Trump out in
2020